dudy plays officer computer yeah dudy
should play if that's possible D would
you like to read uh uh officer computer
it would be my honor to play officer
compuer in Pizza the movie okay okay
this is Officer compuer I was just
minding my own business driving down the
highway headed back to the office to
call it a night when I could swear I was
smelling pepperoni and cheese and
mushrooms and black olives and sauce and
dough like I said I don't know nothing
about any type of party officer all
right all right all right I get it no
party guess I'll just pack up and be on
my way then he walk slowly back toward
the door finger tracing a lazy line
across the tops of one of the pizza
boxes actually he turns back around to
face Jojo and the
others would you mind if I bought one of
these pizzas might be nice to take it
back for the boys you know no sale oh
come on it's not like you don't have a
few to spare I'll give you a big tip